Rainbow six siege the beta has concluded
but my boy Scott Butterworth you he saw
more content than they were showing over
at Ubisoft tell me about it yeah we
actually got a chance to go just last
week and play some post beta new content
material stuff that he was often showing
off the big one really was the
situations which is a sort of
single-player training mode okay it's
kind of the closest thing seems is going
to have to a campaign it seems from what
I understand they're one field 11
different situations at launch and each
one is basically a mission that focuses
on the unique talents of a different
operator so it's different tactical
situations like the the one that I spent
the most time plane was called tubular
assault and it was a infiltration
mission where I had to enter a an
aircraft and aircraft that had landed on
a runway and eliminate a bunch of
terrorists who had like hijacked the
plane and it was it's interesting
because they're each situation is really
designed to just teach you about
different strategic elements and
mechanics that sushi has to offer so
like it'll teach you about destructible
environments and creating lines of sight
for yourself or finding different entry
points or learning about an infiltration
and again like I said each mission is
sort of designed to use a different
special ability that because each one is
built for a specific operator um so they
were they were actually a lot of fun
they were very engaging and if they feel
relatively substantial I mean it is
essentially like a tutorial or training
mode so it's not really a substitute for
full campaign but they are designed
specifically to be single player so you
can kind of get a lot out of them and
learn a lot before you jump in online
and just get like totally slaughtered
and do you get because there is I don't
know if this is going to be the full
retail game you basicly have to like buy
your operators with the currency neither
get from playing the game and if you did
the tutorials in the beta you've got
currency does this tie into that or you
do know how that's going to like
function in the final game right they
didn't they didn't touch on that um it's
possible I get the impression that again
these are sort of intended to be
tutorials but I imagine any gain any
game with in-game currency they tend to
reward you for playing yeah I suspect
that this will tie into the currency
system
but can't confirm that okay and within
these situations did you see any new
operators that we haven't seen or did it
yeah actually um so in addition to
situations they also let us play a bunch
more pvp nice and even some PvE you have
to play a bunch of terrorist hunt which
was really fun both bomb defusal and
just terrorist elimination but yeah
within those aspects of the game we got
to try out a few new operators who had
not previously been playable at any
point all right most of them were
defenders so the game you know roughly
divides or doesn't roughly it divides
its operators you have ten attackers and
ten defenders right depending on which
side you're playing you get to choose as
operator so we mainly saw new defenders
um let's see so we saw a new guy named
glass and actually he was playable in
what in the second of the two of the
available situations um he's sort of a
distance ranged character like a
mid-range to distance sniper character
his special ability is a it's his
special tool is like a night scope on a
long to mid range sniper rifle and you
can actually flip the scope on or off
depending on how you're using the
character so that's that's pretty useful
as like a support character maybe
hanging out on the outside of a building
um to kind of eliminate people as they
try to infiltrate we also saw a defender
named cap caen uh he is sort of a trap
setting character Aaron affectionately
refers to him as the ankle murder guy
basically he can set up laser trip mines
on door frames and I think windows as
well basically if you if you don't
notice them and you break that plane you
will just be flown up mom and that's
kind of like fun and exciting compared
to just like you know putting up a
barrier this is you know explosions are
way more fun version of that and the
last one I think we saw was a guy named
and I can never say his name right but
it's like duh chumki all right Oh
Tatanka Tatanka I think I someone I'm
like even looking at her a sheet I can't
even like read it phonetically he was
another defender he has a tripod mounted
lmg oh wow it was a little finicky like
where you could actually place it in the
game wasn't super clear about there were
hard points you had to connect with yeah
what you had to be next to a specific
object in the environment interim and so
you can't just set it ever lay down and
put it up exactly so you have to be
strategic in and learn where you can
actually set it up but still if you find
a choke point and you're able to like
place it that sounds deadly it is brutal
so that he can be if you find the right
use for this guy to be incredibly so
especially if you like funnel people the
right way using your teammates it can be
really really deadly yeah and I imagine
they showed off some new maps because
that's one of the things that they kind
of have shown a lot of it wasn't is
nothing like super exciting and report
back we did see a couple new maps um we
saw a map called Oregon that was the
thing about the maps we saw actually
that hadn't totally been true increase
taxes there were maps of multiple
buildings so you could actually go into
the wrong space on on accident
potentially okay there's a little
trickier for the attackers because you
still have you know your drones you can
send in and yeah doubt but if there are
multiple buildings that really
complicates things so that was really
the interesting twist on the new maps
that we saw and that kind of ties back
to some of the defenders that you saw to
like a guy with the night scope could be
in one window looking through like you
happy person yeah I mean that's the cool
thing about C's right yeah getting all
these tools and you can use them in all
these different ways and that's really
what the games all about cuz before like
with you couldn't really go outside as
the defenders which you know balance
wise is probably fair or else everybody
would just like run out the window and
kill each other on the street before
they got inside the house or whatever
but i guess like with the duel you know
dual building sup second second
beautiful new lands for sure um and the
last thing we thought wasn't really
related to anything but it was actually
really cool they there's a spectator
mode which sounds really kind of like
dry and boring um but it seems really
well-executed it's really robust you can
actually like zoom the camera all the
way out into like a bird's eye view of
an app and it lets you you can actually
shift the camera by floors you can see
nice a sort of Sims SQ of everything
that's going on really haha for even
more maps you learn the line for Joe
points you see what people are setting
things up so it's a great way to learn
the game and you can also of course like
go into first person view and switch
cameras and see you know the entire
match from different players
perspectives um it's only built so that
there can be all there could only be one
spectator at a time so I'm guessing that
they did that so
that person could actually stream what
they're seeing yeah so you'll have like
twitch streamers and things like that as
the one spectator operating like as the
cameraman when the experience but they
give you a lot of tools and and this is
actually kind of the perfect game for
that sort of thing because when you're
in the match it can be difficult to
figure out what everyone's up to but
having a top-down view and being able to
switch cameras so easily makes it really
simple to to learn everyone's tactics
and to get a really unique perspective
on the action yeah I guess if you had
more than one there would be rampant
just using the spectator mode cheating
if people have little to ya solo or that
isn't it but I imagine they've
considered that yeah we'll be able to
prevent anything like that happening and
that's on all all the versions it's not
just a PC function that's like
everything yeah as I believe yeah they I
think they actually showed it to us on a
ps4 nice I'm so as far as i know yes
that is available on all excuse of the
game that'll make streaming super like
easy for people who want to just watch
cool stream yeah I think that's the
intention like I think that they
secretly have some like eSports
ambitions video they're gonna kind of
let the community decide if that's gonna
happen because really it is up to the
community if it really is going to catch
on but clearly this is built with that
sort of thing in mind yeah every stops
never tried to jam a shooter down anyone
throw as an eSports shootmania looking
at you but anything else anything else
you have to report back no I mean it was
just it was fun to get to jump back in
the game do more terrorist hunt stuff
and I enjoy the situations that I'm
happy to see there's a little bit single
core content I mean we know that there
are going to be some narrative elements
we'd like know that Angela Bassett's in
the game for example so I ok i jus did
this bill tie into the situation's right
I mean that just makes sense is ding
chavez in the game that's what i want to
know if it remains to be seen all right
but clued those elements are gonna tie
in somehow it have to imagine they
didn't talk much about that but you know
hey we'll find out when the game comes
out
you know six or so weeks yeah i'm
looking forward to it i'll be on pc what
you can play them up in peace for I'm a
cop right well thanks dude for reporting
back and for everything else you want to
do be sure to be at gamespot com
gamespot com that's what a game